ils se sont quittés le soir du 15 mars
et il se retrouve masqué pour le conseil
d'installation présidée par le doyen
pierre déjean le conseil municipal qui
se déroule à la ferme du manet à voter
pour choisir le nouveau maire et les
adjoints de montigny le bretonneux la
séance va être ouverte va y avoir un
secrétaire option moi je vais être
désigné président au bénéfice de l'âge
et puis je vais mener l'élection du
maire et une fois qu'il sera élu bien
écoutez je retombe à ma place c'est lui
prendra la sienne mais avec le titre de
maire moi je ne suis que président de
séance avec 33 voix pour l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de jean luc ourgaud
cinq voix pour son opposante karolinska
haut de la liste
m et un vote blanc laura merker devient
le nouveau maire de montigny le
bretonneux
nous avons dans le cadre de ce pro du
programme de la campagne déclinée un
certain nombre d'items sur l'écologie la
sécurité sur la rénovation de l'hyper
centre
nous avons aussi les jeux olympiques
donc tout cela évidemment reste notre
préoccupation et en même temps nous
allons aussi faire avec ce qui vient de
se passer parce qu'on ne peut pas faire
comme si rien ne s'était passé
et tout cela aura forcément des
conséquences négatives et sans doute
positive aussi je pense à la façon dont
les gens se sont organisés les réseaux
de traite qui se sont mises en place et
sur lesquelles il faudra que nous
capitalisons aussi donc nous allons
travailler sur tous ces aspects pour la
liste d'opposition m
cinq sièges ont été obtenues vivien gasc
conseiller municipal d'opposition digère
encore la défaite mais se prépare déjà
pour les prochains conseils municipaux
après notre objectif c'est de rester
dans tous les esprits dans l'esprit de
la campagne une opposition constructive
qui vient faire des propositions qui en
alerte en vigie évidemment sur tous les
projets qui sont portées par les
municipalités
mais qui l'a poussé montigny à être
toujours plus en avant sur sur les
questions écologiques notamment et de la
démocratie
participation l'équipe municipale se
rassemblera le 2 et 22 juin prochain
pour les conseils municipaux
le budget de la commune sera notamment
voter à ces dates